Herr Walter, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 48 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie? Genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 15. Juni 1978.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie?
Herr Doktor, warum diese ganzen Fragen?
Ich habe Schmerzen und Sie fragen mich nicht nach meinen Größen.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Können wir nicht immer kommen, Herr Doktor?
Herr Schäfer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
48.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 17.04.1976.
76.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schäfer?
Ich bin 183.
183.
Und wissen Sie, wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege so 90 kg.
90 kg, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Manga?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5. Juli 1966.
1966, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 163.
Wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege noch 71 kg zur Zeit.
Okay. Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Manga.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
44.
50.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 1. Mai 1970 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1.75 m groß.
Ich wiege ungefähr 85 kg.
Okay.
Was fühlt es sich her?
Warum ich heute komme, heißt ich.
Seit ungefähr ein zweites, ein Wochen.
Ich fühle mich sehr erschöpft, müde.
Und habe gemerkt, dass ich mich nicht mehr erinnert habe.
Und habe gemerkt, dass ich etwas gelb werde.
Erschöpft mich da und?
Dass ich gelb werde, meine Haut sich gelb verferst.
Okay.
Hab Sie das auch früher gehabt, oder das war erster Mal?
Nein, ich habe das auch gar nicht selber bemerkt.
Meine Freundin hat mir gesagt, dass meine Augen gelb werden.
Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Am 12. September 1963.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1.64 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
65 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Dr. Hiller.
Ich bin 59.
Am 16. Mai 1966.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1.74 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
75 kg.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 75 kg.
Ich bin 55.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 75.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Mit meinem Schlucken wird das immer schlimmer.
Ich habe immer solche Schmerzen, wenn ich schlucke.
Das sind keine normalen Halsschmerzen.
Das drückt auch hier so richtig.
Ich habe oben in der Brust.
Ich habe immer so gedacht,
hast du nicht gut gekaut,
hast du mal zu schnell gegessen.
Man kennt das, wenn man trockenes Brot ist.
Man denkt, ich hängt mir das fest.
Aber inzwischen ist es bei allem, was ich esse.
Jetzt ist es auch,
wenn ich etwas Kühles trinke,
das mit des Wehtut.
Das ist das, was ich hier in dem Halsbereich.
Vor allem hier,
hier oben in der Brust.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Wie alt?
Ich bin 54.
54 Jahre.
Am 6.08.1979.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schuster?
Ich bin 178.
178.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege nur noch 72 kg.
Ich habe sonst immer 81 gewogen,
aber jetzt wiege ich nur noch 72.
Sie haben 8 kg abgenommen.
Ja, ich habe viele abgenommen.
Das ist auch eine der Gründe, warum ich hier bin.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, in welchem Zeitraum haben Sie diese Gewicht abgenommen?
Ach, ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft.
Vielleicht in einem halben Jahr oder so.
Okay.
Ja.
Und wie heike ist Frau?
Ja, okay.
Entschuldigung, Frau Schöne.
Kein Problem.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. Juni 1974.
1974.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 groß.
Und 70 kg schwer.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Angaben.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
74.
Ja.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Sie fragen mich das.
Am 21. April 1950.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schöne?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin 1,65 m groß.
Und wiege 75 kg.
Ja.
Herr Breitling, wie alt sind Sie?
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 30. April 1966.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich bin 1,89 m.
Und wiege, ja, ist es viel, 150 kg.
Und derzeit?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Ja.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. März 1962.
14. März 1962.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie seit Herr Hauskote?
93 kg.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
61.
Wie lange sind Sie geboren?
Am 19. Januar 1963.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,86 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
94 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unterträglichkeiten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie heißt der Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Das ist der Hausarzt.
Das ist der Herr Dr. Meiser.
Meiser.
M-A-Y-S-E-R.